hey guys how's it going so
um
big news i don't know if it's really big
news or not but psy mr gangnam style
released a follow-up to his number one
worldwide hit single gangnam style
are we still doing that we are still
doing that gentlemen is the song
and the irony of all of this as i'm
watching it i started thinking wow sorry
you really are a gentleman until we got
towards the end of the video i know you
are not a gentleman you're humping
street cones
what are you doing
most importantly the first thing that
crossed my mind is what the heck is he
saying because there's only three words
that i feel like i can actually
understand in english mother father
gentleman and i have a feeling that he
probably was trying to
say those really quickly so it sounds
like
sorry my friend i'm on to you buddy not
only bad to say about the song other
than psy you are not being a very
gentlemanly
man what i do want to do is read you
some of the english translation the bad
part is i don't actually know if these
translations are correct allah maya
hallahallah wait this is original lyrics
i don't know if you know why it needs to
be hot i don't know if you know why it
needs to be clean i don't know if you
know it'll be a problem if you're
confused i don't know if you know but we
like
we we
like to party hey there if i'm going to
introduce myself i'm a cool guy with
courage spirit and craziness
what you want to hear what you want to
do is me damn girl you so freaking sexy
okay we get the point we get the point i
don't know if you know why it needs to
be smooth i don't know if you know why
it needs to be sexy i don't know if you
know darling hurry and come be crazy i
don't know if you know it's crazy crazy
hurry up oh it's getting good now hey
there your head waist legs calves good
feeling good good it's soft i'll make
you gasp i'll make you scream
damn girl i'm a party mafia
i'm actually crying because i have tears
in my eyes from trying to hold my
laughter in
i'm a muddler butler gentleman
you are none of those things you may be
a father i don't know if you're a mother
i mean you might be i know you're not a
gentleman i'm a
mother father gentleman
tell me more about what you are oh how
about you tell us what you're gonna make
happen you're gonna i'm gonna make you
sweat gonna make you
you know who i am i am wet sigh what
gonna make you sweat gonna make you oh
my gosh
like i can't even make this stuff up
like look wet side what what sweet sweet
savior of mine oh my gosh
i'm a mother father okay great so i hope
that you guys all enjoyed this english
translation oh my goodness i hope that's
even right i mean how am i supposed to
know i don't even know what he's saying
and i don't even know how to translate
let me know what you guys think of the
new sci music video um
i'm going to be the first probably not
the first to say that it made me a
little uncomfortable especially after
reading the english translation i'm a
wet what what i don't even know i'll see
you guys in another video i need to go
i need to like shower or something
you